welcome to this video lend the man let
the man do I know this guy doesn't have
a name in them yeah play no I don't know
for maybe about 15 years i'm playing in
the dutch league so I know quite a
number of dutch players he doesn't have
a name in there though so just a matter
of guesswork King the ship malenko's
laughs this is what Kramnik recently
played in them London classics against
them I think Luke McShane um yeah I'm
getting old what is what was what did he
play was that wasn't dc5 him ok let's
castleford I think Luke took on before
here and played 97 if I'm not mistaken I
only wondered what about 96 instead
instead of taking I mean oh you can also
go here what about Bishop e3 there's
this night shift fri
yeah probably this so why do you go nazi
to jump maybe
yeah I need to get the pong back at some
point we should be III maybe or should I
take I don't really see how to get to
get this poem back
maybe I need to do something else
entirely okay like I do something
something else completely of transposing
I mean I transforming this position
so this way I'm getting the porn back
and um I maybe have chances to play okay
this was it's a principled option um
other I've chances to to put some
pressure on him because of the King
position and the structure okay this is
very curious why why is here running
around with the king k may be here
Bishop e6
okay you want to take with the with a
night
I could have played 95 instantly like
this was strong on Jack this is so good
but not not the best way to play ya can
even take this first Jack want to go
Bishop e3 check now trying to get
something on this on the skin so FYI
drug d7 now this looks on Luke c7 is
quite strong this is mate who gave seven
mate
it's not so easy to prevent this got
terribly misplaced pieces a4 and before
yeah but still whoop Dee 7 can you can't
check on c1 but rook f7 mate mate mate
is made as the end it really doesn't
matter what I'll just else is going on
with your mate ok fate I go Roxy 7 yeah
you can give gift checks here we should
have one check king of three it done
then it's curtains jack will get 78 can
only give some spy check now only 20 g 2
they always need to look for checkmates
this sounds like a very stupid advice
but playing for me this is a very
effective strategy it often crops up out
of out of nothing I mean okay the king
is you see that the king is a bit a bit
tricky here but our pieces are in play
and now you you you you really have him
in having a family meeting net I don't
think yeah it plus 6 plus 6 is quite
quite quite much yeah because of the
mate the computer wants to place silly
stuff like 93 to avoid the immediate
mate and after after what what he played
it's probably already yeah this is a
force made now there's even a quicker 10
made in six okay Bishop c5 is stronger
according to the computer hmm
interesting now but this is also made
just a bit why not okay because of the
the spy check cm rook we should be to
rook e1 and stuff okay yeah I don't know
as I maybe did something wrong here yeah
this is not not the original idea of
this opening but yeah it's okay probably
it's not so so easy for black toe to
untangle well taking here is at least I
don't know slightly better for white I
guess because something my minor pieces
are stronger bishop on c5 and stuff but
he cannot I think if he play something
else let's say Here I am I go go back
something like this for example it's not
so easy now to continue maybe am I have
have this this kind of ideas and and
then attack here also just we should be
three two nights would be able to be
nice in this structure because this is
God weaknesses maybe I can also just go
here black needs to consider things like
this activating pieces and hoping to be
active enough this is an interesting
line but somehow this opening is played
two differently maybe hear you play
something else I don't know yeah thanks
for watching